What will happen. The Joe
Rogan experience. It's
funny cause inevitable let,
like you do a lot of,
I noticed that the whole MMA stand up
making everyone laugh and then you hide.
No, you were, you haunted as
well. You know what it is, man.
I don't have anybody
telling me what to do,
so because I don't have
anybody telling me what to do,
I gravitate towards things that I'm really
interested, which is why you're here.
Right. You know what I'm saying? Like I
found out about your story. I was like,
that guy seems cool and I saw youtube
videos. I go, oh, he's cool. All right,
let's do this. Yeah, I mean that's like,
to have that kind of freedom in your
life is a beautiful thing and I feel
incredibly fortunate that I have that
kind of freedom. So I indulge it.
I indulge it like a little baby,
like a child.
Like I just gravitate towards things
that I like to do and you know,
people could say it's stereotypically
toxic masculinity or what it was. Okay.
Yeah, I like it. It's like,
I'm nice, I'm a nice person,
but I gravitate towards manly shit.
I like watching fights.
I liked doing martial arts, fighting
while I buy. It's like buying a cars.
I like cars.
I like these things.
I mean I'm one of my got to pretend that
I don't like them to make other people
feel happy. Some people feel intimidated
by that. Like, oh, it's too Mami.
Oh that's the problem is you don't
want to look like an asshole.
Which I've experienced. You know, I look
like an asshole. I'll tell you this.
I'll just look at me just like
I look like an asshole to me.
I'm sure I look like an asshole.
The other be true.
I don't think preciate that I started
to go, wow, this guy looks like a,
like a decent guy coming out
of that fancy Tesla. Actually,
I would think you're an environmentalist
and I probably douche bags probably
like Super Vegan. He looking at
it and annoying, right? Yeah.
Doesn't want your kids to get vaccinated
doing the shit you want to do that. That
that's, that's definitely a big deal, man.
So I, I definitely respect that about you.
I feel that more people should do that.
And I think one of the things that we
have a problem with people doing what they
want to do is cause we don't get
to do what we want to do, right.
So when we see other people, they're
like, yeah, that's bullshit. We get mad.
Or we like, he doesn't even really like
that stuff for he's, you know, Oh yeah,
you're,
you're just falling into the typical
stereotypical masculine behavior.
Maybe explore your sensitivity.
The
man will say that because the coaches
telling you how to do shit. I hate that.
It's usually men that are bitches.
Yeah. There's a lot of those.
Funny how that works. Yeah. Got Any
names for me now. I'll write them down.
I'll write them down. So speaking of that,
so interesting story for you. So, um,
yeah,
I was,
I was kind of talking back to tier guy
back and forth about being on the show.
And the craziest thing happened where,
you know,
I was out here attracts you work on a
Tufts related project. Oh. Uh, and um,
to top secrets going to come out in a
couple of months, but basically, uh,
is that my job? Right. And then
I was like, hey, listen, um,
I got to take a week off to go out to
California to work on this project.
And then I was talking to your
guy and they're like, hey listen,
you're going to be out here. Come
back the next week as well. You know,
if you could say, hey listen,
you have two weeks out here.
They told my boss and he's like,
listen man,
like two weeks is kind of a long time. You
don't have any coverage. Like, you know,
I know you can be on Joe Rogan.
It's really cool,
but I'm not sure I can
let you do that or not.
So made a decision following in
your light. I said, you know what?
Then I'll leave my job then.
Oh Shit. Yeah. I left my job,
man. Damn. I left my job,
which is why I'm here. I need a
job. Joe, just fucking with you.
Did you really leave
your job? I did, yeah.
It was a big thing because I had this
whole meme thing going on my youtube
channel. Uh, and I used to say,
oh, I have a full time job.
I can't work on these bills. I
can't do this. I can't do that.
I was getting in the way and you
have no idea. I finally left,
and this is kind of
the, I was reading, um,
your story awhile back about how you
got started in the whole comedy thing,
how you went out, you flooded
in Boston, went to La,
and it just felt so liberating
because literally, you know,
when you're doing something
you're not passionate about,
that's literally eight to 10 hours of
your day doing something that you just,
you just don't really want to do.
It's most of your day. It's, yeah,
because most of your day, so,
so it's insane. So I thought
to myself, you know what?
Everyone's in the rat race,
everyone's rushing to get somewhere.
Every year you're in your,
you know, the ball Boston,
like you're rushing to get on the train,
you're rushing to get somewhere
that you don't really want to be.
You're rushing there to work for eight
hours for someone else doing something
that you don't want to do and it just
gets taxing, man. It was, it was,
it was just taxing.
So,
and you're not going to do your best
with the things you do afterwards.
If you've been doing this thing for eight
hours, four hours that you have before,
you really have to go to bed.
When you get home at night,
you're not going to have the same kind
of energy that you had at noon or 10:00
AM or whatever it was when you woke up
or when you got to work your, what you,
what you're dealing with is this past,
this crossroads, right? You, you've,
you've hit this path where you can decide
to either not take a chance and just,
you just slowly take like
little incremental steps
towards what you really want
to do or take a risk, right?
And when you take a risk, yeah,
you don't have health insurance,
dental, you don't have to, right.
That's what the risk is all about,
right? That's, that's the only way.
And people like, yeah, but what if a fool?
But you can't think like that
because if you think like that,
you're gonna fail set. And
second of all, yeah, you might,
but then you got to do it again.
And if you continue to just fail and do
it again one day you'll figure out why
you're failing.
If you're paying attention and if you're
doing your work and then you'll find
something that you can do
that you're successful at.
If somebody wants to hire you,
if you're good at your job,
if you go to a place and you're
valuable to that employer,
you could be valuable to yourself.
You just got to figure out how to do it
or what it is that you want to do that
you could do without having a boss
without, and something that feels natural,
something that you are,
you're,
you gravitate towards when you get up in
the morning and go, I'm fucking pumped.
I'm going to like, I work for myself.
Yeah. And I'm gonna do my thing. Right.
There's not a time where ever come
here to do a podcast while I go, fuck,
I can't believe I have to do this right
out of time. I must feel good. Thank you.
Yeah. Not Today. Not ever. Never. Never.
I mean, there's times when I leave.
I was like,
what the fuck was that about?
I could imagine there's a
couple that's in a thousand,
whatever podcasts I've done,
there's only been like a small
handful of those that have been like,
what fuck was that? Right.
If you can do that, man,
if you can find that
thing that you love to do,
whether it's making furniture or
fucking painting or whatever it is,
if you can ask it so you can make
a living doing that. God Damn,
that's everything. It changes the world.
The world becomes a better place. Yeah.
That's the goal, man. So, so we'll see.
So again, I took some cues from, uh,
from some inspiration from you when
you left Boston and you're like,
you know what? I'm going to do this comedy
thing. I want to figure it out. So what,
what was that like for you? So when did
you make the determination to say, hey,
you know what, I work at
this Gig, uh, you know,
this isn't the thing that I want to do.
And you made the jump, like what does it,
what was that like? The Boston
thing was super lucky. Um,
I was only 25 or less,
24 dash 24.
And uh,
I was doing standup and I was driving
limos during the day and doing a bunch of
different odd jobs and shit. And then, um,
I got seen by a manager who is coming
from New York to Boston to scout for new
talent. Okay. I just got dumb luck.
I wasn't even supposed
to be on the show and uh,
he asked me to go to New York
and do some spots in New York.
I did some spots there and then, uh, next
thing you know, I was living in New York.
I signed a contract with them and
I just upped packed up my shit.
And my grandparents were
still living in New Jersey.
They live on north ninth street,
which was like a,
when the time when they first moved there,
it was a pretty nice neighborhood,
middle class. But then as New York has
got kind of Funky, it's like skid row now.
Yeah, well it's just, it was
the next door neighbor, uh,
while I was living with him,
they broke down his house door
cause he was selling crack. Oh,
he had a dope Audi parked in his
driveway and they smashed his door with a
battering ram. And as soon as it was
a legit, that was an experience. Yeah.
Sketchy neighborhood. Um, but
that, so that's what I did.
I just packed up my shit and moved. I
mean, I didn't have any money. I didn't,
I didn't know if it was going to work
out at all, but I knew this was a chance.
But I was young. When you're
24, you're like, whatever,
health insurance, whatever.
I didn't have health insurance for a long
time. Do you have it now? Yeah. Okay,
good. That's good. Yeah. You got it.
Did you hate it when you quit this job?
Do you have it? At one wife has it. Okay,
well, there you go. So that was a scary,
just like, Shit. Hey, listen, what does
she say? She go for it. Ooh, I like it.
Good.
You've got a good one.